Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here!
Following the success of Maleficent and Cinderella,
Disney continues the live-action make-over
of their classic animations with The Jungle
Book.
Drawing on both Rudyard Kipling's original
stories and Disney's 1967 animated feature,
this new Jungle Book is an absolute feast
for the eyes.
The film almost seamlessly blends live-action
performance with absolutely astounding CG
locations and amazingly photo-real animals.
You'll almost not believe that you're watching
mainly computer-generated images, so convincing
is the VFX work by WETA, MPC and Digital Domain,
as well as Animation Supervisor Andrew R Jones
and his crew.
When I reviewed Pixar's The Good Dinosaur
last year, I said that the stunning realism
of the landscapes made you feel as if you
could reach out and touch them.
And the same is true of The Jungle Book...
it's all so incredibly life-like: from the
beautiful waterfall to the pouring rain, ravines
oozing mud, grass swaying gently in the breeze,
and the movement of leaves on the trees.
It really is a sight to behold.
And I saw this movie in 3D, which made it
feel like an even more immersive experience.
At the heart of The Jungle Book is newcomer
Neel Sethi as the movie's only human character,
Mowgli.
Sethi does a great job, especially considering
not only has he never acted professionally,
but he also had to act with CG characters
in this film.
He really does respond beautifully well to
whatever's needed of him, whether in the more
action-filled scenes, the quieter sections,
or the more humorous moments.
The one place he's not as skilled is the singing
department, but that's not such as big deal
as he doesn't have so much to do there.
As for the movie's starry voice cast, it's
pretty superb all round.
Ben Kingsley is perfect as the black panther
Bagheera, bringing a wonderful gentle but
commanding quality to the part, a performance
which I rate as highly as Sebastian Cabot's
original take on the character in the 1967
animation.
Idris Elba takes a completely different tack
to the fabulous George Sanders' sleekly-voiced
villain Shere Khan, giving a much more overtly
menacing tone to the tiger who's desperate
to get his claws on man-cub Mowgli.
In this version of the story, Shere Khan gets
much more screen-time, and I liked Elba's
suitably powerful and steely portrayal, which
nicely fits this fresh interpretation of the
tiger.
And I love the way the sound guys seem to
have sometimes mixed in real tiger growls
underneath Elba's wonderfully rich, resounding
voice.
Of course, if you know the original animation
well, you're not going to forget Phil Harris's
brilliant John-Wayne-style Baloo voice in
a hurry, but Bill Murray really is very humourous
his role as everyone's favourite lazy bones
bear, and his take on the character definitely
works for me.
Oh, and we get to hear a little of his rendition
of the fantastic Bare Necessities too, though
I would definitely have loved more!
Taking on jazzman Louis Prima's role of King
Louie, Christopher Walken puts his distinctive
voice to good use playing the now King Kong-sized
orangutan as a mob boss.
Although Walken sings a couple of verses of
'I Wanna Be Like You' with some new lyrics,
the way the song's introduced doesn't feel
as natural a fit in this version of the story
as it was in the animated movie.
Lupita Nyong'o puts in a tender turn as Mowgli's
wolf-mother, Raksha, alongside the always-welcome
presence of Giancarlo Esposito as his adoptive
wolf father, Akela.
Scarlett Johansson brings a fittingly mesmerising
lilt to the python Kaa, and underneath her
voice the sound department has added a little
snake-like hiss and the occasional sound of
a snake's tongue flicking, which really adds
to the whole snakey effect!
It's a real shame she's only on screen for
a short time, and, given she's a singer as
well as an actress, I would have loved to
have heard her perform Trust In Me during
the actual movie.
By the way, do look out for a prickly little
comic cameo from the late Garry Shandling
in what's sadly his final role.
The Jungle Book kicks off at a breathless
pace and screenwriter Justin Marks ensures
there's plenty of adventure and humour alongside
darker and more emotional moments.
And there's one particular part of the movie,
which I won't spoil for you here, that's actually
handled in a much more interesting way than
in the original animation.
There's also a bunch of Easter Eggs and call-backs
to the original animated movie, and I'll have
a video on that up soon, so don't forget to
check it out when it's live – there'll be
a link here!
Director Jon Favreau, who gave us the much-loved
modern Christmas classic Elf and successfully
kicked off the Marvel movie juggernaut with
Iron Man, clearly hasn't lost his touch.
Although one action scene cut have done with
a little cutting, Favreau, along with Matrix
cinematographer Bill Pope, keeps up the movie's
energy through most of its 105-minute run
time.
And composer John Debney has written a rich
original score, which also nicely brings in
themes from the 1967 movie.
By the way, if you're someone who normally
bolts straight out of the cinema as soon as
the film's finished, don't do that for this
movie.
Make sure you stay through the credits as
they're brilliantly imaginative and you'll
get to hear three great songs, two of which
you hear snippets from in the film, and a
third one that you can only hear in the credits.
So, to sum up, The Jungle Book is a gobsmackingly
gorgeous movie which combines unbelievably
brilliant technological wizardry, a fantastic
cast, and enough nods to the animated classic
it updates, even if it's not quite everything
you'd want it to be in the song-and-dance
department.
Oh, and it's a real treat to watch in 3D.
The Jungle Books gets 4 out of 5 Flicks.
Now, tell me what do you think about The Jungle
Book?
And who are your favourite characters in the
movie and why?
Let me know in the comments below!
As well as my Jungle Book Easter Eggs video,
I'll also have spoilery review of the best
moments from the movie up soon.
I'll add annotations here once they're ready
to watch!
If you like this review, it'd be so great
if you'd share it, and do subscribe for more
videos on Disney, comic book movies, Star
Wars, and more!!
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!